in the countryside of argentina cowboy
life has scarcely changed over the past
three centuries the gaucho is a hero
here a legendary figure
larger than life but these are the real
Gauchos men who still live this life the
way as a gaucho if there is such a thing
as a classic Gaucho it is Don Jose and
Sola he believes solitude helps preserve
the purest form of Gaucho life she no
pudiera ramirez in el campo if I
couldn't live in the Campo the
countryside an unthinkable thought I
don't know what I'd do I'd rather live
in a shack out here than in a palace in
the city there's too much I'd miss the
sound of hoofbeats the birds are dawn
sipping mati in the clean air no city
has that
Argentina virtually the last refuge of
this lifestyle is home to nearly 150,000
Gauchos their herds thrive in this sea
of grass which means that a Gauchos work
is never done
lucha Kanjilal ELISA is a struggle
against nature is very beautiful so
difficult in winter it's cold and wet
from morning to night in summer brutally
hot but somehow it all gives me strength
it nourishes my soul the life of a
gaucho is one of adaptation to a climate
to a landscape and to an ageless way of
life
that even now sustains them